jacques et stéphane guillon
[Musique]
alors c'est à dire bonsoir mari alors le
csam interdit de dire quel est le livre
de stéphane guillon ou stéphane guillon
est sur scène non plus que fait stéphane
guillon ce soir avec la division pharma
là
donc on ne dit pas dit pas mais vous
pouvez dire ce que vous avez préparé non
juste avant de commencer je voulais dire
à eric de montgolfier que je vous en
veux un peu voilà parce que depuis que
vous avez mis bernard tapie en prison
maintenant il fait l'acteur etc vous
n'êtes plus pénible pour tout le monde
commence par une bonne nouvelle cécilia
sarkozy regarde l'émission qui rit ouais
la semaine dernière je m'interrogeais
sur la sexualité du petit nicolas est
bien des lendemains cécilia me répondait
dans libération sarkozy c'est le pied
alors nouveau test nicolas en at il une
grosse peut-être une réponse demain mais
est ce que c'est important
quand même vie sociale les sans-papiers
s'installe chez ni [ __ ] ni soumises moi
si j'étais sans papiers ce qui n'est
déjà pas très rigolo quitte à
m'installer quelque part je choisirai
une [ __ ] soumises
aéroports
aéroports nouvelles restrictions
draconiennes tous les liquides sont
interdits en cabine résultats steveen ne
pourra plus prendre l'avion avec martha
barrière qui est quand même très très
liquide
politique
politique dans vsd le pen se réfère à
clemenceau c'est vrai il ya beaucoup de
points communs entre le pen et le porte
avions ce sont deux vieux rafiot l'un à
plus de radars l'autre est borgne en 99
le clemenceau perd son hélice le pen sa
prostate turbines au point mort est à
sanitaire détestable 1 et bourré
d'amiante l'autre et xénophobe les deux
sont bretons malheureusement les
mouettes ne chie que sur le clémenceau
[Applaudissements]
attention si l'un a été désarmé l'eau
peut encore frapper le coulé très vite
toujours dans vsd le journal analyse la
gestuelle des politiques moi j'ai vu des
titres de films laurent fabius dans
haïti et les aimer aux
le pen affreux sales et méchants
philippe de villiers choix très très
choquant jacques chirac à bout de
souffle françois hollande ma femme
s'appelle reviens
fait-divers encore deux bébés en moi
cette semaine un noyé façon villemin un
congelés façon courjault il n'y a pas
que la star ac pour devenir connus pour
endiguer cette tendance le journal le
parisien vous propose pour 12 euros une
fausse une avec la photo de votre petit
une façon d'épater vos potes sans
trucider bébé
attendez après c'est pire
à ce propos la mère du petit david a
tenté de se suicider au liquide
vaisselle elle c'est raté bah oui si
vous avalez du liquide vaisselle faut
courir et boire en même temps faut que
ça mousse sinon ça marche pas
[Musique]
première sortie publique d'isabelle
dinoire la greffée du visage elle boit
elle fume elle rigole bientôt la reprise
d'une vie sexuelle mais là la famille du
donneur s'inquiète c'est quand même la
bouche de notre fille trop tard donner
c'est donner
[Rires]
mondialisation la société ikea emploie
des travailleurs asiatiques payer 0 90
centimes d'euro la journée leur slogan
c'est ikea est là ikea est là pour les
[ __ ] la deuxième partie du slogan est
moins connu
attendez tirer on est en train de me
dire que l'audience de l'émission
s'effrite légèrement donc je vais poser
une question ou non je posais une
question à michel bernier pour que l'eau
du casque est prête si vous permettez
michel je voudrais tordre le cou à la
rumeur il paraît que vous avez une
aventure avec zinedine zidane
c'est bon l'audience reprend on va
sauver l'émission j'aimerais
télévision commence par une devinette
sur la table de nuit de pascal sevran il
ya quelque chose qui fait mal au cul à
votre avis thierry qu'est ce que c'est
mais je ne peux pas eh bien il le dit
lui même dans la presse j'ai mis la
photo de sarkozy à côté de celle du
mythe et ans c'est vrai que ça fait mal
au cul
on se demandait comment olga la chienne
de michel drucker pouvait endurer chaque
semaine l'enregistrement de vivement
dimanche notamment un spécial chez la
pauvre bête eh bien on a la réponse sur
les chiens souffrent aussi d' alzheimer
pour elle à chaque fois c'est son
premier vivement dimanche
pis paul il ya quinze jours madonna
adopté david un petit malawi et bien
cette semaine lollobrigida 79 ans adopte
xavier rigo un jeune avocat de 34 ans
son cadet il est propre il mange tout
seul et surtout il est formé
presse on termine par un voici
particulièrement immonde cette semaine
le journal inaugure une nouvelle
rubrique la torture morale la recette
prenez jacques martin qui est paralysé
dans un établissement médicalisé puis
achevé le en publiant des photos de sa
femme batifolant avec un jeune homme
fringant dans le même temps voici offre
une cafetière au lecteur qui s'abonnent
pour les filtres utilisés des papiers
cure vieux truc de scouts où c'est
encore mieux le journal lui-même voilà
merci
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu